brace yourself this is gonna be big
two
two three
four
seven looks easy right
14.
three two
two one three
two eight three seven
one seven five
four five zero
one three nine seven five nine
six zero zero
six eight three seven six
two five one oh
six seven eight seven
you want one more
they get big two six six four three
seven
one four four nine one six six
four eight six oh seven eight four four
and the next one gets a lot bigger and
they keep getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
what are these numbers
well you don't have a clue right i
wouldn't have a clue myself
where did they come from yeah okay well
the where they came from is actually a
puzzle a genuine puzzle sequence
and it's a triangle so i show you the
beginning of the triangle and i ask you
to explain how i'm getting from one row
to the next the zeroth row just has a
single number in it too the first row is
one one second row is one two then one
one two yep
then one one two three and then
one one one two two three four
they're getting bigger and bigger the
next one one two three four
two two two three three four four five
six seven and so on
this is lionel levine's triangle and how
is it defined
can you figure it out
give up okay let's see how we would go
from one one two
you read it from the back and this tells
you how many ones there are so there are
two ones in the next row this says how
many twos there are there's one two and
this says how many threes so the next
row is one one two three okay how do we
go from one one two three to this row we
read it from the back the three
says we begin with three ones the two
says the next we have two twos that one
says we have one three and this says
that one says we have one four and we
keep going in that way so here again we
have four ones three twos two threes two
fours
one five one six and one seven that's an
extra and you keep going
that's the triangle and now you add up
the numbers in each row so here we get a
two one plus one is two one plus two is
three and we get four so these numbers
are the sums of the numbers in the rows
and
it's an innocent looking triangle but
when you follow it for a few rows you
get
a triangle which is bigger than any
computer memory could possibly hold
[Music]
that is that is faintish i don't think
anyone would get that in a job interview
no unless they could cheat
just in case you're wondering what would
come next in this sequence because
obviously there are more than nine
digits now
what we do is we have
seven ones six twos five threes four
fours
four fives three sixes
three sevens a couple of eights a couple
of nines and a couple of tens
and then 11 12 13 and 14. so we're using
full natural numbers
not digits
so for the sum of this row we add the
natural numbers not the digits so for
example 11 is treated as 11 not two ones
and the total of the whole row
is 213
and so it continues
you can find out more about this
sequence and many other sequences on the
online encyclopedia of integer sequences
and this is entry number
a011784 and we've got plenty more videos
with neil sloane who's the founder and
keeper of the oeis there are links on
the screen and in the video description
we have to always go to a new square and
by the way if you're into podcasts we
have a number file podcast have you
listened to that yet
and i have another podcast called the
unmade podcast with a friend of mine in
australia called tim i'll have links on
the screen down in the video description
[Music]